Hello, everyone. Welcome to the Lang focus channel. And my name is Paul.
Today. We're going to talk about the Caucasian languages.
The Caucasian languages are named after the Caucasus mountains,
which are situated between the black sea and the Caspian sea,
and more or less serve as a geographic border between Europe and Asia,
the Caucasian languages are spoken in and around the Caucasus mountains,
the Caucasian languages are actually not a language family.
They are a regional grouping of languages. And within that regional grouping,
there are several language families.
The families normally included within the regional grouping. Our Kartra Lillian,
which used to be referred to as South Caucasian,
Northwest Caucasian and Northeast Caucasian.
There are other language families present in the caucuses,
including Indo-European submitted Turkic and Mongolia,
but they're distributed over a wider area and have indigenous speakers outside
of the region.
These particular three language families are indigenous only to the caucuses,
which is what makes the members of this group of languages.
Carillion has around 5.2 million speakers,
mainly in Georgia around 4 million of them speak Georgian in Georgia, of course,
but also by a minority over the border in Turkey, as there by John and Russia.
The other cart really in languages are [inaudible] laws,
which has spoken mainly on the Southeast coast of the black sea in Turkey and
spun.
This fun branched off from Carillion around 5,000 years ago.
And the other branch split into cart or Georgian and Zan around
4,000 years ago,
then Zen began diverging into mean Greeley in at laws in the seventh century
when their speakers were separated into different territories. I mean,
brilliant in-laws are the closest to,
to in languages and have some degree of mutual intelligibility. However,
it's worth noting that many or even most speakers have mean Grillion laws and
spawn the ones who live in Georgia that is also speak Georgian and Georgian has
traditionally been the written language for all Vili and speakers. So of course,
those bilingual speakers can also understand Georgia Northeast Caucasian
languages are spoken by around 3.8 million people, mainly in dog Istan,
Chechnya, English Petia and parts of Northern Azerbaijan.
The most widely spoken languages include Czechian with 1.5 million speakers
of our,
with 1 million lesbian with around 800,000 and English with around
500,000 Northwest Caucasian languages are spoken by around
2.5 million people,
mainly in up Kazia the kebab Dino bell calorie and Republic,
the [inaudible] Republic,
and [inaudible] there are four or five main languages,
Cub guardian or Easter Cashin with around 1.6 million speakers OD the
gay or West, sir Cashin with around half a million speakers.
Many of them in Turkey,
in the middle East at the cause with around 190,000 speakers.
And Abaza with around 50,000,
I should point out that the Circassia people also known as the ADI gay people
consider both the East and West branches to be the same language and refer to
all varieties as other gay. And they are mutually intelligible with each other.
There's also the extinct language, which was quite an intriguing language.
As we'll see later,
the Northwest and the Northeast Caucasian languages are thought by some
linguists to be branches of a single language family,
the North Caucasian languages, but this is still controversial.
[inaudible] is widely accepted to be unrelated to them yet,
despite the huge diversity within these three language families,
there are also numerous shared features due to mutual regional influence.
In other words, the Brock Boont effect common features,
all Caucasian languages are continental languages,
meaning that consonants are heard with more frequency than vowels in cartwheels.
And specifically, there are lots of big consonant clusters, for example,
skinny. This means they peel us. Of course the meaning is nonsensical,
but it's an example of how big the consonant clusters can potentially get the
Caucasian languages are also known for their rich continent inventories.
In other words,
they have lots of distinct consonants the degree to which this is true,
depends on the language family and on the individual language.
The court really and languages have comparably few distinct consonants,
28 for Georgian and 30 for laws.
That's similar to the 28 of Arabic and the 36 of Russian note that I'm
talking about. Consonant sounds not written consonant, symbols,
the Northwest and Northeast Caucasian languages have much larger inventories,
especially in Northwest Caucasian.
The now extinct Uzbek language had over 80 distinct consonants.
And sir Cashin has 50 to 60 consonants depending on the dialect.
That may sound impossible. How could there be so many consonants? Well,
it's in large part due to secondary articulation.
If a consonant has secondary articulation,
that basically means that it's pronounced in two different places in the vocal
tract at the same time, like two continents at the same time,
one primary continent,
and then one extra continent pronounced along with it that secondary
articulation might be palatalization with the tongue raised towards the hard
palate,
liberalization articulation with the lips valorization the back of the
tongue raises towards the vellum, globalization, the closure of the glottis.
And so on one type of continent with secondary articulation,
that's common to the Caucasian language.
Families is ejective consonants in any objective continent.
The glottis at the back of your throat is closed and the larynx is quickly
raised, which raises the air pressure in the mouth.
This creates a popping sound. When the primary consonant is produced,
all of the languages have ejective stops. Let's hear some electives in Georgia.
Uh, uh, sir, uh, uh, uh,
an example word, meaning water in all of.
The languages stops have at least a three way distinction between voiceless
aspirated stops voiced stops and ejective stops.
Uh.
Here's an example word in Chechen, meaning bridge,
listen for the slight popping sound that accompanies that sound
sir Cashin in the Northwest Caucasian family has ejective fricatives as well for
a total of at least 10 objectives, or even more, depending on the dialect.
Pull, pull, pull, cheer,
cheer, slow, and the word meaning black.
Another common feature is contrast between Vilar and uvular stops.
For example, in Chechen.
Good, cool con connect.
Agglutination. The word agglutination comes from the Latin word,
a gluten naughty meaning to glue together.
That gives us an image of how words are formed in a gluten native languages.
Words are created by gluing together a linear sequence of morphemes with each
morphine representing one piece of meaning that's slightly different from
fusional languages in which those additional morphemes can contain multiple
pieces of meaning. Here's an example from Chechen Mola.
This is a verb in the infinitive form, meaning to drink.
The law. This means.
To start drinking this suffix creates the inceptive form to change to
the past tense. We can first remove part of the ending and replace it with this.
Mold delete. This means.
Started drinking in the recent past,
but it's something the speaker has no direct knowledge of.
Delete. This.
Means started drinking and I saw it happen with the suffix at all.
The verb is in the witnessed past. The speaker witnessed the action happening.
This type of feature is called evidentiary city.
All three families have a feature called evidentiary nutty,
which means that verbs are inflected to show whether the speaker has evidence of
the action or not.
This feature entered carte Vivian through Turkic influence though,
in the other families, it likely existed before contact with Turkic speakers,
especially in the Northwest Caucasian family,
Caucasian languages also generally display SOV word order though,
this is not equally true for all families or languages. Georgian,
for example has SOV,
but also SVO depending on what the focus of the sentence is with the focus
coming before the verb ergots activity,
all three families display or negativity though,
the cart really in language mean Grillion does not.
You may be wondering what the heck is [inaudible] sometimes I still ask myself
that same question.
It's a feature that's quite rare among the languages of the world.
Some other ergots of languages include Basque, Kurdish, Hindi, and Tibetan,
basically in an ergot of language, the,
of an intransitive verb and the direct object of a transitive verb are treated
as the same. They are in the same case,
the absolute of case let's give an example in fake English.
We'll pretend English as ergotism. He sleeps him, loves she,
you can see that the object of this sentence is in the same case as the subject
of this sentence. Why that's so weird. Think of it like this.
These two pronouns are in the same case because they both fully received the
verbs action in an intransitive verb.
The subject undergoes the action in a transitive verb.
The object number goes to the action. So they are both in the same case.
The absolute of case,
the subject of the transitive verb is treated differently because it doesn't
receive the action it's in the ergotamine case. Yeah,
but that's in fake English, right? Here's an example in Georgian,
meaning the student went student immune reader.
This sentence means the student wrote the letter.
Student [inaudible].
So you can see that student in the first sentence is in the same case as letter
in the second sentence student in the second sentence is in a different case.
Georgian has mixed or Cotivity with the feature,
not appearing in all tenses or with all verbs,
but other Caucasian languages are more consistently ergotism
features shared by two of the three families. As I said before,
the Northeast Caucasian and Northwest Caucasian languages are thought by some
linguists to be part of a single language family referred to as North Caucasian.
So they have some shared features that Kartra Lilian doesn't have, or does have,
but to a lesser degree,
I already mentioned that they have much larger consonant inventories,
then Carter Ilian, for example, they have laryngeal consonants.
These are consonants pronounced in your voice box at the back of your throat,
your pharynx or your blotters Northeast Caucasian has the most, for example,
in Chechen.
Oh, a couple of example, where it's.
Custom or habit and meaning swamp or Marsh
and insert Cashen.
It's easier to hear these sounds in an actual word.
This means Bay or Gulf. The only laryngeal sounded Kartra.
Lillian is hut like the H sound in English.
They also have liberalized consonants,
which means the consonants are produced with the lips rounded at the same time,
for example, in Circassia.
Crew crew crew,
and an example word.
They also exist in Chechen, but in Chechen, they are non phonemic.
They are aliphatic, which means they're not perceived as separate continents,
merely as variations of an existing continent.
North Caucasian languages often use non finite verb forms,
verb forms that don't any tents like participles in English, such as reading.
These are normally used as modifiers instead of relative clauses,
Northwest Caucasian. And Kartra really,
and also have some things in common that Northeast Caucasian doesn't have.
One major example is poly personal verbs.
Poli personal verbs can have inflections for more than one person in the
sentence, including the subject direct object and indirect object.
Here's an example in Georgia. [inaudible] this means they will show us.
This is the direct object marker. Meaning us. This is the pre verb,
which helps distinguish certain tenses. This is the root meaning show.
And this is the subject marker. Meaning they, and in sir Cashin.
Yes. Thus, this means I gave it to him or her.
This is the indirect object marker. Meaning him or her.
This is the subject marker. Meaning I, this is the root meaning.
Give this indicates the predator that form. In other words, the past tense,
this indicates the verb. As in the affirmative here,
the direct object is left out because it's clear from the context,
but sentences that include it are also possible.
The genetic links of the Caucasian languages to other language families are
completely unknown, which has led to some interesting theories.
Some people believe that Kartra salient or the North Caucasian languages,
or both are related to Basque.
That's because of some shared features like ergotism and poly personal verbs.
The basket cart really in connection is not widely believed anymore,
but there are still some who think basket might be very distantly related to the
North Caucasian languages, Denae Caucasian.
This is a proposed language family spanning Eurasia and North America,
which includes North Caucasian Buddha Shefsky in Pakistan,
see Tibetan Yenisei in the nod, Denae languages and the vest, conic languages,
including Basque.
This theory is not widely accepted and remains very controversial.
The huge linguistic diversity of the caucuses,
as well as the difficulty in clearly determining the connection between the
different languages there makes it a fascinating region to examine Caucasian
languages also have quite different features from languages elsewhere,
which makes learning about them a mind-bending experience.
The question of the day.
What do you think about some of the unique features of Caucasian languages that
I talked about in this video? Do any of these features appear in your language?
A big, special, thanks goes out to my Patrion supporters,
especially these ones right here on the screen.
They're my top tier Patrion supporters.
And that's why their names appear in the video patrons of different tiers get
different benefits, such as access to the private Lang focus online community,
check out
patrion.com/lang focus and consider becoming a patron and to everyone.
Thank you for watching and have a nice.